okay hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others and i can see that
we have a whole bunch of questions that
um was saved up from a previous time
so let's see where should we go first i
have a question here from mikhail
is sociology a real science can it
predict
something that's an interesting question
so places where
science has probably been most famously
successful
are in physical sciences predicting
things originally it was motion of
planets
then it was all kinds of things about
the physical world that's a place where
where mathematics where where science
aided by mathematics has been has been
very successful
actually i noticed one thing i'm sorry i
need to
do a little change here because we
forgot something
um okay the uh
um in uh
so
the the the um the question is what
about
doing science where the entities you're
dealing with aren't planets or atoms
they're people and one's trying to deal
with understanding
what happens in kind of the the social
world and so on
can one make a a science
of the same quality so to speak as
something like physical science
when the elements one's dealing with are
things like people
you know back a long time ago i think it
was in the early 1800s there was this
idea that there would be a social
physics
that would be kind of the analog of
sort of the laws of mechanics and things
that one has in physics about you know
force equals mass times acceleration all
those kinds of things
that there will be laws like that that
would govern
social processes just as there are laws
that govern physical processes well
there were various theories the various
theories that have sometimes had
grand and not very positive consequences
for the way the world is organized
um that uh there would be sort of a
grand theory of how those kinds of
things would work
but it doesn't really pan out you know
when you look at it kind of
on the ground and you say are the things
that people do
somehow predictable or or are they
fundamentally less predictable than
things in physics
the actual practical experiences they're
remarkably predictable in many ways
like for example if you look at people
visiting websites
you get you know billions of data points
of people
clicking on these pieces of websites and
going from here to there and all that
kind of thing
and you can make all kinds of curves
that show you know the average
time people spend on this part of a
website and how they move to other parts
and so on and you look at those
aggregate curves and they're very smooth
curves
they have very definite forms and you
compare those curves with the curves
that you would measure
in some physics experiment with
particles or some other thing
and actually those curves often look
much scratchier
than the curves you get from looking at
how humans behave
when they're visiting websites and so on
so that kind of makes one think
gosh there should be some kind of analog
of a social physics
or something that will tell one things
about sort of the general principles
for for the operation of of what humans
do
um either individually or collectively
but uh
and there are some sort of rules of
thumb that are known
but we don't really have the same kind
of framework
that we have for something like physics
in understanding those types of things
i mean i suppose an area that is uh sort
of in the middle of these kinds of
things is economics
um where there's sort of a question of
uh what
uh what is the role of economics as a
science-like thing and so
you know if you look at a typical
economics textbook there'll be a fair
amount about sort of
the mechanisms by which the world
exchanges money and so on
there'll be a fair amount about the
history of you know
when people left the gold standard what
happened in the
in the great depression these kinds of
things are sort of a story of what's
actually happened in economics
and there'll be a small amount of theory
about economics
and that theory what is the character of
that theory
that's an interesting question because
it's often
sort of mocked by physical scientists
because in economics
you'll see you know there's this curve
oh it it goes you know the demand for a
product
there's sort of some elasticity of
demand and you'll draw a curve and it'll
go up and it'll come down again
and somebody will say what does the
curve really look like
you know how can you fill in the exact
data points and know exactly what the
curve looks like
people say we don't really know what the
curve exactly looks like
well the interesting thing is it often
doesn't matter exactly
what the curve looks like because what
you're really trying to get out of
uh economic reasoning so to speak is
a sort of chain of explanation a chain
of sort of
logical deduction which just says well
if you charge more fewer people will buy
the product those kinds of things
and well you know that's a different
question from if you charge five percent
more will
2.7 percent less people buy the product
those kinds of things
it's something where there's a there's a
form of kind of reasoning about what's
going to happen
that isn't doesn't have quite the same
kind of uh perfect mathematical
quality that one's used to in things
like physics now there are areas of uh
of economics where uh you know there's
all sorts of
uh sort of places where one uses uh
statistical models in economics and
where one can say well there's this
number and this curve and so on and so
on and so on and one can try and make
some statistical predictions
about what's going to happen based on
that but i would say that a lot of kind
of economic reasoning
is more at the level of something more
like logical deduction
than it is a sort of it's quantitatively
informed logical deduction
more so than it is kind of something
like physics
where we write down an equation and we
solve it um now
it's an interesting question uh when you
look at a you know a textbook of sort of
fancy mathematical style economics
and it has all kinds of equations and
there are all kinds of solutions to
things and it's it's all sorts of
complicated things are going on
and you say what really is this is it
something that is like
an axiomatic theory like in in some area
of mathematics where we say
assume that consumers have the property
that if things cost more they buy less
of them
assume that consumers have this kind of
rational behavior property
assume this and that and the other where
we can sort of define the world
by a set of axioms and then build on top
of that this very elaborate kind of
mathematical structure of seeing what
the consequences are
is that what it's doing or is it more
something that's like statistical models
where you say
we observe the following thing and you
can fit this curve
by this sort of two parameter uh thing
and so on
where does it lie in those things and i
think that's not completely clear
and i think probably people different
people have different views about about
the way to think about that
so you know a question that comes up
in sort of these kinds of things that
comes up certainly in economics is can
you predict things
is it a is it a kind of activity a kind
of intellectual domain
in which prediction makes sense can you
say something like you know
if a government spends an extra trillion
dollars on a stimulus
thing for this then inflation will do
this
is that a predictable thing or is that
something which is only sort of an after
the fact but we can tell a story about
why it happened
i think that um uh it is one thing to
understand
is that not all forms of science
are uh is the key issue you know predict
what's going to happen
in fact that idea about how how science
works
is an idea that's specific to very
particular kinds of science
uh that that happened to be popular
starting about 300 years ago
i mean so if we look at different kinds
of science and what
sciences have predictions versus what
sciences work in different ways
it's sort of interesting i mean in in
physics the big thing
was an early thing was you know predict
where this comet is going to be
predict where this planet is going to be
we write down an equation we solve the
equation
we can figure out oh this is where the
thing is going to be
then we come to a field like biology
well a dominant theory in biology
is the darwinian theory of natural
selection
that isn't really on it on its own a
predictive theory
it doesn't really say things about oh
you know based on this theory we know
that there'll be dinosaurs for a while
and then there'll be
mammals taking over and so on after the
fact we can start saying well we can
understand why it worked
that way we can we can reason by
by use of that theory but it isn't a
theory which which immediately gives us
oh we predict this is going to happen
now there are plenty of other fields
that have at least the word science and
their name
uh computer science for example not
really a predictive
theory of anything it's a insofar as
it's sort of a
science it's a science that attempts to
understand
and reason about computer programs and
so on
and i think that the the idea that sort
of science is all about
you know you make a prediction for
what's going to happen um
that's a very specific type of science
um and i think that the um
another thing to realize is one of the
things that's sort of a
result of work i've done over the course
of many decades
is this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that even when you know
the rules by which a system operates
even when you've done
the most successful thing that physics
wants one to do which is you know drill
down
find the fundamental laws um even when
you've done that and been successful at
that
it can still be the case that to work
out how a particular system behaves
can be arbitrarily difficult if it takes
the system you know a billion steps
to figure out what it's going to do you
might have no faster way to work it out
than follow those billion steps and i
think computational irreducibility
is something which uh there are only
very specific kinds of questions you can
ask even in physics
that don't run into computational
irreducibility and some of the early
ones about you know motion of planets
and
things like this are ones that that have
this feature at least in their simple
cases
that they don't run into computational
irreducibility when it comes to
questions in let's say biology
when it comes to questions even about uh
properties of molecules things like that
one can quickly run into computational
irritability
at which point it's like well yes you
can run the computer simulation
and just figure out sort of step by step
how the system works but in terms of
having a big sort of
ex big sort of theory where you can say
i'm going to
uh sort of put a small amount in and
then jump ahead and predict what's going
to happen
you're not going to be able to have that
so there's a question in
in sort of the social science area to
what extent even if there were
underlying laws that were known to what
extent there's computational
irreducibility
in how things actually work to what
extent you know it's a it's a question
of great interest when people say
let's put in place this policy about how
the world should work
well what are its consequences going to
be well we have
you know if we could do if we had a
perfect social physics so to speak
we just say okay we tweaked this
parameter this is what's going to happen
in the world
we can decide if we want that or if we
don't want that but we know what's going
to happen
the problem is there are in almost
inevitably unexpected consequences
that's kind of a feature of this
computational irreducibility idea
you can't sort of know what's going to
happen in advance so you can't guarantee
that there won't be unintended
consequences
it's the same phenomenon that makes it
common for there to be bugs and programs
that people write
it's like well you think that you're
writing this but there's an unintended
consequence that there's
that you consider a bug that's over here
so i think
that the um uh the the question of what
um
uh whether one can imagine in the social
domain
is one full of computational
irreducibility and unable to make
sort of predictions beyond just watch
what happens and then
maybe sort of be able to explain things
after the fact
or are there places where you can make
predictions one of the things that's
important
in science is sort of knowing what
um what battle to fight that is what
kind of a thing might you try to predict
you know i'm fond of pointing out that
um in babylonian times
there were sort of three kinds of things
that the astrologers thought they might
be able to predict
where planets were going to be the next
day what the weather was going to be
like the next day
and whether some king would win or lose
a battle the next day
and you know it turns out we figured out
how to do the planet prediction thing
we're kind of a certain distance along
the figuring out the weather prediction
but there's a lot of
computational irreducibility there and
the winning or losing of battles well
that's kind of still off the table so to
speak
and and i think it's it's kind of the
realization that there will be things
that
science is just not you know even if you
know the underlying rules you can't
figure out what's going to happen
it's an important realization and kind
of understand limitations of science but
one of the things to say is when it
comes to sociology social science
whatever
it's like what battle are you going to
fight you know
what kinds of things might you talk
about where you might be able to have a
sensible predictive theory
so for example you might ask the
question i don't know
let's say you're looking at um uh stock
markets and you're looking at in
economics and you're looking at
price fluctuations and you see that oh
things are roughly sort of randomly
going up and down but there's a long
tail here
can you explain that is there a a
predictive theory that explains how long
the tale should be
is there a predictive theory that tells
you oh if this
feature of of uh interest rates changes
then this will happen and so on
um well the the the question is which
kinds of questions
are you likely to be able to have
answers like that to and which are you
not
so my guess is that there are a class of
questions to which
there will be kind of traditional
science-like predictive answers and
maybe we know
a few of them but they're probably a lot
more and they're also ones where
it's just not going to work it's a story
of computational irreducibility
it's it's not a thing where you're going
to be able to make
your traditional kind of science-like
predictions now you know
people often say you know one day there
will be for
for sociology you know a newton of you
know
an isaac newton-like figure you know
isaac newton was famous
in well most particularly for his book
in 1687
um principia mathematica mathematical
principles of natural philosophy
book that kind of really pushed the idea
of using mathematics as a way to
understand the natural world
people sort of say maybe one day
there'll be a newton of social physics
and all of those web curves and all
those things that describe people
there'll be some way of turning those
into kind of newton's laws type
type laws and um i think
that if you pick the right battles some
of that may happen
i think there'll be plenty that where
that won't happen and even in physics
if newton had said the thing i'm going
to explain is
is the random turbulence in fluids well
newton would have been out of luck
because his methods and his sort of
prediction in science ideas wouldn't
have worked
so uh now you know having made all these
comments i would say that just as a
as a matter of sort of uh a footnote
perhaps i i i happen to have been
thinking a little bit about economics
myself recently
and i'm particularly curious about sort
of the
uh some fundamental questions like what
generates value in you know what makes
things have value and i kind of have a
suspicion that there may be some
some very definite scientific things
that can be said about that
that revolve around computational
irreducibility and so on
that are not things where you're going
to be able to say and i predict the
answer will be 7.4 and these kinds of
numerical quantitative mathematical
things but where you will be able to
understand
this is this is why things work this way
and you'll be able to reason in somewhat
different form
about what kinds of things can happen
that was a very long answer to that
um okay let me see
other kinds of questions here
well right another rather philosophical
one from uh gistnoisis
should we use inductive reasoning in
science
that's sort of related to some of the
things i was talking about so first of
all let me explain what inductive
reasoning is
so if
if you're doing something like
mathematics
you can say two plus two we know the
definition of two we know the definition
of plus
we can say two plus two is four no doubt
about it
it's just based on definitions of twos
and pluses and things like that
but if we say uh the um
um i don't know a um a star that has
been
of the size of the sun is going to turn
into a white dwarf
or if we say something about uh how
uh objects that are uh you know if we if
we throw a ball it's going to follow
this kind of trajectory
those are not things that we can in the
usual way of thinking about physics at
least
um that we can just say by the
definition of what we're talking about
by the definition of throwing a ball and
so on
we know it's going to follow a parabola
to know it's going to follow a parabola
we have to actually observe
how the world is actually built it's not
something that is
inevitable just from the definition of
terms or sort of a
purely logical deduction it's something
where we have to deduce from the world
what's going to happen we have to throw
balls a bunch of times and notice they
all follow parabolas
and then say okay there's a general law
that says
that in the world parabolas are followed
when you throw balls
so there's a question of to what extent
does that work
to what extent can you say i observe
this i observe this i observe this so
the next time it's going to be the same
way
i'm going to observe this in physics
it's worked quite well
in some of kinds of areas of biomedicine
and things like that it's a little bit
questionable
because it's sort of the basis in a
sense for a lot of the way that we think
about medicine today
you know this thing worked for 100
people
okay let's try it on 101st person of
course it's going to work because it
worked on 100 people
well usually but not always
you know that's that's uh you know one
in x number of
people will have this bizarre reaction
to this particular
drug or some such other thing inductive
inference
you know this kind of scientific
induction didn't really work
the fact that we saw something work a
bunch of times we tried it again
and by golly it didn't work the way that
it worked before
now can we do any better probably not
why didn't it work that hundred and
first time well because that particular
person
had a different genetic makeup or they
had a different
um uh you know they uh eat many carrots
every day and nobody else in the
in the study ate lots of carrots and the
drug reacts with uh
you know with beta carotene or who knows
what i mean in
in um um you know all kinds of different
details
can be there i think that um uh one of
the questions is when you do an
experiment in science
uh to what extent can you really control
the parameters of your experiment
you know in physics we tend to be able
to do reasonably well in many
experiments we tend to be able to say
we've got this isolated system it's
going to work exactly this way
when we do experiments in biology it's
much more difficult to do that i mean we
can
we can breed our mice to be you know
exactly the the same genetics of mice
and they've been
raised in exactly the same way and you
know they're in this mouse colony and
maybe there's some repeatability
in how the mice behave but when it comes
to people for example
you know we've all had different uh
different histories and done different
things and
all those kinds of things and and it's
not going to be sort of
you don't have such a controlled setting
for doing experiments
and so that means that this idea that
just because it worked once it's going
to work again
doesn't necessarily work now is there
any is anything better one can do
not really that's the best way we know
to sort of infer things from this from
the world
is just look at what the world is like
and say it's going to be more of the
same
that's that's typically the best thing
we can do now sometimes we can say
we can drill down and we can say this is
what the world looks like in these cases
but actually what we know is really
going on is this thing underneath
and when we've got the new thing to look
at we can say let's look at the things
going on underneath
and see how those those work and then
maybe we can predict a different thing
here
now so so in other words the the um
i mean there are fields of science oh a
famous example
history you know human history it's like
can you use inductive inference on human
history just because something worked
that way before
will it work that way again you know
just because
no empire has lasted forever does that
mean that
no empire that comes into existence in
the future will last forever
just because we see this or that happen
does it mean history will repeat itself
you know people are fond of saying and
particularly when they talk about you
know
uh grand uh innovations in business and
so on that
they're fond of saying it's different
this time you know
what uh the stock market is is going to
go up and it's going to keep going up
forever it's different this time
usually history does tend to repeat
itself
but can we use sort of inductive
inference in general
to think about sort of historical
processes
it's pretty iffy because like dealing
with different people in some medical
study
you know there's always different stuff
going on you know at this time in
history
we're able to start you know having
talking to people remotely through video
conferences and things like that at this
time in history
uh the um uh you know the way that um
uh the way that some aspect of
technology works
is different so it's different now we're
not going to see the same phenomenon
that happened in the middle ages
because after all now uh people live
much longer technology is much better et
cetera et cetera et cetera
well i think that um there's sort of a
multiple things going on some of that is
true that there has been
sort of change through history but some
parts of it uh you know really
human nature so far hasn't changed much
in in recorded history it seems like you
know the stories one reads from the
earliest stories about uh
what humans do and do do with each other
and so on
is uh are pretty much the same as what
we would see today
um and i think the uh uh so those are
the
those are sort of drivers of of success
in
in in sort of inductive inference for
history because the human condition
really hasn't changed much
but then there are other things that are
different and so on so i think it's a
it's a complicated issue where one can
expect to make use of this kind of idea
of
we've seen it that way before it's going
to be that way again
now i will make one footnote to all of
this about about
the about science and the study of
the use of inductive inference in
science
one of the things that i've been engaged
in the last year or two
is trying to find a fundamental theory
of physics and it's looking like it's
going really really well
it's looking like we actually have
successfully identified what the kind of
low-level machine
code by which the universe operates is
we don't know the details of all the
rules
but we know the structure the formalism
by which things can be set
up and so essentially what we're doing
is we're reducing physics to mathematics
we're saying this is the precise machine
code for the universe
this is you know we have these sort of
atoms of space and they're interacting
with each other and they have all these
the whole formalism of multi-way graphs
and
all kinds of things but in the end what
it's saying is
it's just a formal thing it's just
something where
like two plus two equals four the
processes
by which space is constructed time works
black holes are formed you know
particles exist
all these kinds of things they're as
definite and inexorable
as the fact that two plus two equals
four now
it's uh you you can ask the question
well what aspects of our universe are
kind of necessarily the way they are
and what aspects are kind of like oh we
were given this universe not another
universe
uh you know what what aspects with two
plus two equals four
we kind of have the idea that just by
the definition of two and the definition
of plus
the result is inevitable to what extent
is that the case that when it comes to
our universe
we can say the same thing that things
are inevitable about our universe
what i'm coming to realize and maybe i
won't go into this too much detail here
what i'm coming to realize is that um
the the answer to that
is that there is in a sense a a
a complete inevitability to many aspects
of the universe
and there is in fact only one universe
and it it is the way it is
and it has to be that way and there's no
other possibility
but the view of the universe and our
perception and description of the
universe
even the fact that we talk about things
like space and time
and particles and all those kinds of
things those things
are very contingent they're very
dependent on us
they are our particular way of
describing the single thing
that is this the universe as it has to
be so to speak
and so if we say well what about those
extraterrestrial
aliens who might who also live in the
same universe
are their descriptions going to
correspond to the descriptions that we
have
of the universe and the answer is no the
answer is that
even at the level of talking about oh
the universe
exists in space and there's you know and
there's matter
and there's gravity and things like that
there are
different views of the exact same thing
that is our universe
that will lead one to have a quite
different story that one tells about how
the universe works
and so in that sense our physics is not
inevitable
the universe is i think inevitable but i
think that the description that we make
of it
by in the way we would describe it in
physics is
is dependent on on the way we exist and
i can kind of start seeing that by just
imagining
what would it be like if uh you know
each of us was the size of a planet
what would it be like if each of us was
the size of an atom
um how would our how would our way of
describing the universe be different
it would be very different in those
cases in the in the case of
you know you're the size of a planet
things about the speed of light
being limited start really mattering you
don't get to
for us normally you know we look around
we see in the distance
uh the light that comes to us from the
distance that we can see
if we're not looking out through a
telescope into space the light that's
coming to us
has arrived in some tiny fraction of a
second
some some some amount of time very short
compared to
the time it takes us to to think about
what we're seeing
so so for us it's sort of instantaneous
but if we were the size of planets or
or solar systems or whatever you know it
could take hours
for for us to sort of know about
what when we when we move our hand to
know
what happened so to speak and depending
on our sort of brain processing speed
it could be the case that it's like well
we're waiting we're waiting we're
waiting did our finger move or not
because our finger is is off you know in
the position of mars which is 20
light minutes away let's say and it
takes 20 minutes for
for one to know what happened and so on
and so there are very different
perceptions of the universe that one
would have
at these different even at these
different for example sizes and so on
all right so that was a little bit on on
uh inductive inference inductor
reasoning in science
okay there's a question um
oh boy
um
so many interesting things here
ah all right i'll do one that seems
extremely simple
i'm always you know obviously i'm doing
these things sort of spontaneously in
real time
and uh one of the things i've discovered
in i learn a lot from trying to explain
things in this kind of medium
and one of the things i learn is that
things that i immediately say i know the
answer i can explain that
often end up being the more complicated
ones to actually
uh actually explain there's a question
here from uh
william saying what is a number
okay that seems like a dead simple
question but let's see whether i can
can um uh try and talk a little bit
about that
first question is is it obvious that one
should even talk in terms of numbers
why why do numbers exist you know
you have numbers when you want to
describe
for example multiple copies of things so
for example one thing that's
sort of a a fun well both thought
experiment and real thing
people often say oh there are these uh
you know
um these are the sort of uh tribes
living in the
amazon rainforest or something who have
languages that
don't have anything any words for
numbers bigger than
than than three okay so what's really
going on there
and what i realized from talking to
anthropologists and so on
is in those languages for example what
really is going on is there's a word for
one of something there's a word for a
pair of things and then it's just a word
for lots of things
and the question is when does one
actually need to start saying five of
something seven of something
you know eleven and a half of something
when is that needed
you know let's say that you have a bunch
of sheep
well you know in many situations you
might just
know every sheep and they each have
names and you refer to them by the names
of the sheep
at what point do you start having to say
i have 11 sheep
well it's a it's a sort of stage or or
or feature of of society and
civilization
where you start saying well i'm going to
trade sheep each sheep is worth this
amount each sheep
is worth two goats or something and then
i'll trade them and then i have to start
using numbers to to discuss that so i
don't think numbers
it's worth realizing that numbers are
something that are somewhat dependent on
our kind of
particular way of of of setting up you
know typical civilization and so on
and you know numbers became popular back
in things like babylonian times when
people were
starting to organize things into cities
and so on and people started having to
have you know money as a medium of
exchange and have to work out what is
the area of this piece of land
and you know let me count out the number
of the things of bali or something
that i'm going to be get for this amount
of money numbers became important there
the numbers that first became important
were whole numbers
um then there was sort of a lot of
question and confusion
about what do fractional numbers mean so
for example in the babylonian system
everything is in sick one sixtieths
so uh that's that's how we ended up with
60 minutes in an hour
you know and i guess probably also 60
seconds in a minute although i don't
know whether the babylonians had seconds
um but uh this idea that
you know you've got a certain amount of
something where you can have a
fractional amount
it's one sixtieth two sixtieth three
sixtieths and so on
when you start saying well what about
the precise number square root of two
the precise number
which when you multiply it by itself
makes two
well then you have a different kind of
number it's
you know we know that it's about 1.414
or whatever
um but that number that square root of
two number
how do we how do we work out what that
number is how do we think about that
number
uh pythagoras and friends got very
confused about that for a while
because they thought every number that
was worth thinking about was a number
that you could get as a ratio
of two whole numbers a rational number
and square root of two
they they found out is not a number that
can be formed
as a ratio of two whole numbers it's um
an irrational number
that isn't isn't a ratio of two whole
numbers
and it was at first very confusing to
them
that even that such numbers should exist
what what could such a number be you
know is there
what is that thing that represents the
square root of two
and is uh but and is is a number but
you can't sort of get your hands on it
you can't say it's the ratio of these
two whole numbers
where whole numbers we sort of think we
can get our hands on because we can
we can just sort of count them out and
so on
well in modern times we represent
numbers usually as decimals like we'd
say
one 1.414 two six eight five three four
eight et cetera
we have these decimal numbers and we
kind of are pretty familiar with how
those work
but actually it wasn't until the 1600s
that people really started using
things like decimal numbers with
positional notation and so that decimals
fractional decimals and so on and um the
it was actually a very confusing idea so
for example let me give you an example
of why it's a confusing idea
okay so we have the number one
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero going on to infinity
okay that's a number great okay now
let's consider the number
.9999999999 going on to infinity
is that the same number as 1.000
going on to infinity or not it's
numerically equal to one that number
point nine nine nine nine
nine is as close as we want if that
sequence of nines goes off to infinity
that number basically is 1.000
but it isn't written the same way but we
have two numbers that are written
differently well are they really one
number are they two numbers
that's one example of a kind of a
confusion a thing that makes it not
obvious what's going on
with numbers when they're written as
decimals like that and
you know in general the question of
what uh what kind of thing we can
uh we can consider to be a number is an
interesting question i mean like what
attribute should numbers have for
example you might say
well if we've got two numbers better be
the case that x plus y
is the same as y plus x you know if you
add
2 plus 3 is the same as three plus two
just a property of numbers you might say
anything that might be a self-respecting
number should have that property
that uh uh x plus y is equal to y plus
x for any numbers x and y well is that
is everything that you might consider a
number have that property
perhaps not i'll give you an example
this is a slightly
uh complicated example it's the example
of transfinite numbers
so it's invented by god cantor in i
think the 1880s
um so this is a the following idea
so imagine that you count out numbers
one two three four five
and you go on you keep going you keep
going forever you keep counting numbers
eventually let's say you've counted you
counted your counter you counted forever
you get a number omega okay now you say
but what happens if i go even further
well then i get a number omega plus one
go even further omega plus two go even
further omega plus omega
go even further omega times omega and
what what kanto realized is that there
is a meaningful way in which you can
talk about these trans-finite numbers
these numbers where uh the the things
i'm describing are transfinite ordinals
these numbers where you you just keep
counting forever
and then you say well how do i take that
i kept counting forever
and add more things to it well one
feature of transfinite numbers
is that omega plus one is equal to omega
you keep counting forever now you count
one more time
well it doesn't really matter you
counted one more time it's the same as
just
having counted forever omega but um uh
no i'm getting this i'm sorry that
that's the wrong way around
that omega plus one is not equal to
omega but
one plus omega it's like you you put
down the one
and then you go on counting forever and
the result of that
should be considered as the same as just
i went on counting forever
so what that's saying is one plus omega
is omega but omega plus one is not equal
to
omega so it's a case where where x
plus y is not equal to y plus x now you
might say that's not a real number
that's some kind of weird
infinite thing but many for many other
purposes
it's useful to think about these
trans-finite numbers
as examples of number like things
actually just recently i
transferred numbers have not had a great
history of being sort of
useful in the real world i recently have
had a real use for them which we'll see
how it pans out
um but it has to do with understanding
well
understanding the way that proofs work
and understanding the way that infinite
data structures work
and all kinds of other things but any
case the the um
another thing comes up with transfinite
numbers another feature of numbers
is if you yeah this is an interesting
feature of numbers
if you have a number is there and you
represent the number in a certain way
if the number has a certain value is
there only one way to represent the
number in a certain way so i mentioned
0.99999 being the same as 1.00000
that's a place where our usual decimal
way of writing numbers
has this sort of non-uh non-canonical
character
that there are multiple ways to write
the same number
and you could say well i'm going to
canonicalize i'm going to make every
number i'm going to standardize every
number
things get trickier when you have
numbers with square roots
so for example when you have things like
square root of 2 plus square root of
three
that is the same i can't do this i have
to i have to use
both language to to work this out but
that's the same as some other
some other uh combination of square
roots and things
but in general you'll have some big
combination of square roots
in general there may be many different
ways to write down you know you might
write
uh square root of two over two or you
might write one over square root of
two and it's not obvious which of those
two things are are numerically equal
but it's not obvious which of those
forms should be considered
the standard form and it turns out there
are plenty of situations
uh when where there is no
obvious canonical form for
numbers constructed by these various
techniques so if numbers are made from
from adding together and multiplying
together square roots and things like
that you can end up with that situation
actually there is a
there is a way of canonicalizing those
um as soon as you end up
with uh things like trigonometric
functions in the picture
you're you're out of that game there
isn't a a stand
a way to canonicalize things that will
always work and in fact
here's an even worse thing to say if
you've got two numbers
and they're written down as you know
square root of 2 plus pi
times e times whatever you've got some
other number written in some other form
and you ask the question are these
numbers equal okay
so it could be the case that you can
plainly see they're equal
one of them is uh you know pi squared
the other one is pi
times pi great those are equal um
but the thing which is an interesting
mathematical fact is
in general you can't tell whether two
numbers written down that involve
square roots and trigonometric functions
things like that whether these two
numbers that are written down
are actually equal you could try and
work them out numerically
and you can say to a hundred digits of
precision these numbers are equal
to a thousand digits of precision
they're equal are they exactly equal
are they the same number well in order
to tell that
you would have to make essentially
mathematical transformations you would
have to
do things like saying things like you
know if you have
sine of 2 times some number that's the
same as 2 times sine of the number times
cosine of the number
those kinds of things that are that are
exact mathematical transformations and
you might say
well i've got these two numbers is there
a chain of mathematical transformations
that i can make that take me from one
number to the other then that would
prove
that those two numbers are equal well
the problem is and this is a consequence
of girdle's theorem
and a bunch of other things that that
there is no
no limit on how long that chain might
need to be
it might be the case that these two
numbers that are written down are in
fact equal
but that chain the minimal chain
necessary to go from one number to the
other
is an arbitrary number of steps long it
might be a billion steps you might have
to go through
it's like doing a mathematical proof you
might have to go through all these
different gyrations
to show that these two numbers are equal
and in general there just isn't an upper
bound on how long that chain
needs to be so so that's a sense in
which numbers might be equal but you
don't know they're equal
so there's a lot of a lot of tricky
things that can go on there
so that that's a now
you know by the way some of these things
about whether numbers are
uh properties of numbers let me give you
another example in a computer
there is this idea of so-called machine
arithmetic
personally i actually think it's a
pretty bad idea i think a lot of
kind of wrong things were done in the in
the
1970s about how that was set up but it's
kind of the standard way computers work
now so when you have a number like uh i
don't know you're trying to represent
uh one-third in a computer or two-thirds
in a computer
well how does it actually get
represented it's more or less it's
x 0.6666 it's actually in binary not in
decimal but
uh at least on most computers um but um
then the question is uh how many digits
do you actually store in the computer
and the point is this computer only
stores a limited number of digits
it's usually about 53 digits in binary
something like that um and
that is it's a so-called floating point
number usually
so it stores the the uh the number and
then it stores times 10 to the power
something or other
that gives the scale of the number so in
any case when you do that
you can ask questions like when you
store numbers to only a limited number
of digits
is addition commutative in the sense
that x plus y equals y plus x
uh well it's not is it dissociative uh
you know
uh brackets parentheses where
parentheses go and plus signs don't
matter
uh it's not so in other words some of
these things which are
features of um uh when you make this
sort of finite precision arithmetic
are those things that you have in a
computer those machine numbers
are they in fact genuine numbers are
they some weird other thing
they're a little bit weird i'll give you
another example if we have one-third
so one-third of the decimal point three
three three three three
when a computer represents it it's
representing it in binary
so it's representing it just with zero
and one digits and so it's i don't
remember what a third is in binary i
should be able to work it out
point one one point one zero one zero
one zero one zero one something like
that i'm not sure
um in any case the one of the features
of that is
when you you might want to have the
property
that the thing that represents one-third
for you
when you multiply it by three should be
equal to one
well turns out that won't be the case in
when you
truncate it to a finite number of
limited number of digits
you can end up with a situation where uh
the thing you that represents one
third you multiply it by three it's
0.999998
let's say not exactly one and um
in fact for a while people used to make
computers particularly for business
applications that used uh so-called
binary coded decimal
which was kind of a weird hacky way of
kind of packing
decimal digits into triples of binary
digits
in order to avoid things like one-third
times three not being
equal to one but so machine arithmetic
on computers is an example where you
sort of thrust into the question
of you know are those machine numbers
really numbers do they have the
properties that we expect of numbers and
so on
there might be more to say about that
but that's a little bit of um
a little bit on on this question of what
is a number
um
let's see
um
gosh a lot of um
wow okay um
should i talk about here uh
let's see um
well there's a question here i'll maybe
try and do this
the question here from memes of
destruction would computer processing
speed
increase if we had a compendium of
mathematical proofs
okay it's an interesting kind of
question
so what do mathematical proofs tell us
they tell us certain they tell us
results about mathematics where in
principle
if we knew the axioms of mathematics we
could go through and rework out those
those proofs ourselves so in other words
if we're told
certain facts about arithmetic let's say
we could in principle go and work out
everything we need to know about number
theory and this and that and the other
but in practice it's been centuries that
people have been working out all those
details of mathematics
and they've been able to say actually if
we go in this direction
we can get this big complicated result
which we can write down
and you don't have to repeat all of
those steps you just
here's the result great be happy
well and mathematics progresses by
taking those results those theorems
people approved
and saying let's see what else we can
prove by going by building on top of
those theorems
now it's certainly not the case that
we're exploring all
possible mathematics we're making these
kind of highways
of mathematics where we're going from a
theorem we can prove to another theorem
we can prove and then that one lets us
build another theorem
it'd be better to call it a tower of you
know whether where the various
uh bricks and the tower these theorems
we've proved and we can keep going and
keep going building on what we've
already built
if we say okay we actually want to know
about this mathematics often this way
different direction
it's like sorry you're starting from
scratch you've got to start from the
axioms and start proving things step by
step
okay so there's a similar kind of
question for computer programs
so if you write a program you can uh it
could be the case that you've written
this whole big blob of code
and actually somebody looking at that
blob of code could say you didn't need
that whole blob of code
it's just you know x plus one that whole
blob of code you've written just turns
into x plus one
that would be kind of a theorem about
your code that says
this whole big thing is just x plus one
let me give you an example
let's say you have a function reverse
that reverses the elements in a list
so it turns abc into cba okay so
if you say reverse of reverse of a list
that the result of that will be you just
get back the list you started from it'll
reverse it once it'll
reverse the reverse that gets back to
what you started from so it's a theorem
of programming that reversed a reverse
of anything
is the thing okay so you can imagine
these kinds of things that are a little
bit like mathematical theorems but
they're instead
theorems about uh their computational
theorems
about a programming language a
computational language whatever
um and so you can imagine building up a
library
of those kinds of theorems about
programs which are analogous to not
quite the same as mathematical theorems
the the world of mathematical theorems
is quite divergent
from most of what one will be interested
in for computational theorems
but one can build up these kinds of
computational theorems and actually
when when you compile code in when
when you're taking code that you write
in more language
and it's getting compiled into some
low-level machine code or whatever
uh what's happening is there are lots of
those theorems that are getting used
there are lots of theorems that say
this thing will always be an integer it
could never turn into a pair of integers
it will always be an integer
so that means you can always represent
it in the computer in this way
and that's a theorem so to speak and so
it has to happen
when you are trying to say how could you
is it is it good enough to just use a
single integer to represent this whole
thing in this computation
well you can prove the theorem that it
is okay so the question is
if we had a big library of those
theorems how successful would that make
us
in being able to for example even
execute our code faster
because if we could say forget running
this piece of code that's just a theorem
that says the answer is seven
then we don't have to run the piece of
code we just say the answer is seven
okay so here's the here's the problem
the problem is if the code was writing
in the first
worth writing in the first place and
worth running in the first place
then there can't be a theorem that
shortcuts it
if the only way there could be a theorem
that shortcuts it is if actually that
code
would say well you wrote it in a very
elaborate way but you didn't really need
to write all that stuff
you could have just written this short
thing here now
you can be in a situation where yes you
could have written that short thing but
you don't know that
you as you're thinking about it you
imagine it in this much more elaborate
way but actually it turns out that was
that was
you didn't need to do all that stuff it
was actually really much simpler
so that that's a um
uh that's a sense in which one can
imagine sort of a
a a computational theorem being useful
but but in general
those things will be less useful than
you think because it sort of wasn't
right worth writing the program
if you can just jump ahead and say this
is what the answer will be but there are
some limited places where it's useful
particularly in compilation where you're
saying does this program that i wrote
fit into this thing that can be
represented at a very low level
on on this computer and that's the thing
where if you have a theorem that says it
works this way
you may be able to do that and if you
don't have the theorem you won't be able
to guarantee
that you can do that but uh this whole
question of whether
it's important to have a sort of library
of mathematical theorems
i've been very interested in this there
are about three million theorems
that are have been written down and so
the history of human
mathematics um and published in papers
in in the history of human mathematics
and uh i've been very interested in
representing those theorems in a kind of
computable
way as something where when we build up
mathematics for example
we can start to say has something like
this theorem been seen before let me
search
in the set of theorems and identify that
and keep going
that process is actually very difficult
of of curating theorems because we kind
of have to have
a very standardized way to represent
these ideas of mathematics
and that's something we built a long way
in that direction with mathematica and
wolfram language
um but there's still further to go to
represent sort of all the mathematics
that's been done
particularly mathematics that was done
after the beginning of the 20th century
um that sort of diverged a bit from
mathematics that had been done before
well let's see uh
people are asking such elaborate
questions here well
um
okay there's a question
from uh pomenadis what's the worst
computer bug
you've ever had what was the simplest
computer bug that you couldn't figure
out
what is a bug and why do they happen
when you write a program and the program
can do lots of things it's
basically impossible both as a practical
matter as a human and even theoretically
to know what could this program possibly
do
and in certain if for example you might
have a program that's trying to
do some particular kind of computation
and
uh you know that you tested it for a
thousand inputs
worked great okay now in real world
somebody is giving it a weird input oh
it breaks in some
some crazy way that you never could
foresee actually
uh someone was asking before about
scientific induction
it's an interesting case uh software and
software quality assurance is an
interesting case of that
when we build wolfram language for
example
we do lots of quality assurance we do
lots of testing
and so every time you know every day
we're building new
sort of prototype versions of the
language in everyday millions and
millions of tests are running on these
language
on these versions and we're saying did
the results come back the same as they
came back before
are they if they were correct before are
they still correct and so on that's
often a very tricky thing to answer
because
there'll be details that might be
different you know this pixel might be
in a different place on the screen
because
something changed about the way the
operating system did this or that
yet it's still correct even though it
isn't identical
so to speak to what was before but
nevertheless you can say
if the if the tests work does it mean
that the code is correct
and then you can say and and obviously
the answer is no
the sort of scientific induction answer
would be if you ran enough tests
well then you know how the thing is
going to behave but it isn't true
and that's in a sense one essence of
bugs
is the fact that that isn't always true
now you can say
people talk about uh program
verification
can you prove the theorem that this
program is always going to do the right
thing
the problem with that is the definition
of do the right thing
is usually hard to make if the
definition of do the right thing
is oh it doesn't start um
you know scribbling on memory that it
wasn't supposed to be allocated
uh or does it you know could it ever run
forever and never halt
those kinds of things those are definite
things where you can imagine trying to
prove these theorems you might not be
able to do it
but you can imagine trying to prove
these theorems but if the question is
does it give the right answer well how
do you define the right answer
the right answer is probably pretty much
defined by
the piece of code you wrote that is what
you're trying to do
and so that's defining the right answer
so it tends to be the case that you get
in this very circular situation
of saying how do you verify that the
verifier is correct
and really the thing you're writing the
original program you're writing
is the program that specifies what you
want the program to do
now in in practicality there are plenty
of situations where there can be
a bug which is obviously wrong like
you're running your program and it
crashes
you're running your operating system and
it freezes you're
you're trying to you know something is
supposed to remember your login and it
forgot it
these are things where you know it's
pretty everyday to say that's
wrong and um you you have um
so but let me give you an example i've
been studying some abstract systems last
week or two
uh things called tag systems i'll write
something about them soon
and these systems have the property that
they're the very simple systems defined
by very simple rules
and uh the question is you run these
rules you run these rules and eventually
the rules stop applying and the system
just halts
okay well the question is does it always
halt
and the answer is i've got examples
where it takes 202 billion steps
and then it holds i don't currently have
any example
where i can say or i can prove that it
doesn't hold
but i don't know whether it always does
halt or not that's a difficult thing to
determine
and if i had a program where i'm just
going to assume as a programmer i'm just
going to assume it holds
it's like actually i don't know that
there probably is no proof of that they
may even
theoretically be no proof of that there
could always be an escapee
a kind of a version of the input where
it won't in fact halt
so that would be an example of a a very
nasty insidious kind of bug
if i made the assumption that it was
always going to halt but as a practical
matter
well let's see i mean the when i write
code in welcome language which i do
every day
um i would say that that sort of bugs
are not as common as they might be
partly because what i tend to do is
because a language is a symbolic
language it means you can take apart any
program
into its component parts and those parts
can run perfectly well
it's not going to say you know if you
have a low-level programming language
and you take a lump of code out of the
middle of a program
you have to you have to build a whole
harness to run that piece of code
if you have a symbolic language then any
piece of code
just takes symbolic expressions as input
and gives symbolic expressions as output
so you can take any subpart of a program
and expect it to run separately and so
it's much easier
to debug things in that situation and it
makes it
uh now you enter up writing more
ambitious programs
but still my experience tends to be that
when i'm writing wolf language code
it's not super hard to debug um because
i can like take pieces out
and uh and so on and and just see what
they do and i can
put sort of diagnostic things in to make
sure it's doing what it should be doing
and so on the places where things get
much more difficult to debug
when you're dealing with computer
systems and when you're dealing with
particularly things where there are
multiple computers involved
in sort of orchestrating together making
things happen
so for example in cloud computing you
know in our wolfram cloud for example
that's a large number of computers um
and they're all kind of working together
to deliver results to users and so on
and there
there can be very complicated and
insidious bugs so there's one that i
wrote about a few years ago actually
that was a bug that um uh
you make a request to the cloud usually
it works very fast but sometimes it's
really dog
slow it used to be the case okay what's
going on
what's going on well the team was
working on this they looked at it for
ages and it's just
we can't figure out what's going on okay
so i eventually decided i better look at
this thing
so i started looking at it and i started
plotting you know you make a million
requests
some fraction of them are slow uh let's
plot out
both when the slow requests happen and
how slow are the slow requests
so i discovered this really weird thing
i don't remember the numbers anymore but
but
um uh you know when it was slow when it
was fast it happened in 50 milliseconds
when it was slow it took 200
milliseconds let's say
but sometimes it also took 400
milliseconds
and sometimes even more rarely it took
600 milliseconds
so the question was how could there be
something
where it um oh actually the other thing
was it was quite common for it to take
200 milliseconds
but sometimes it only took 50
milliseconds so that right there
is a tremendous clue because if you're
asking a computer to do something
usually it takes 200 milliseconds but
just sometimes
it happens in a quarter that time you
know there's 150 milliseconds of time
wasting going on
because otherwise for it to even be
possible for the computer to answer
you in 50 milliseconds that has to be
something the computer can do
so but in any case the most bizarre
thing was that the
the delays were quantized it was either
200 milliseconds
400 600 800 milliseconds they were in
lumps of 200 milliseconds
i'm not sure if i remember correctly the
200 milliseconds but let's let's use
that for the sake of this
this description but um
so it's like what on earth is going on
here and uh
so uh well it turned out
trying to remember all the details of
this but it turned out i started tracing
down exactly what was happening
where was the slowdown happening what
program was actually running when the
computer was
was taking these 200 milliseconds and so
on it turned out to be inside the linux
kernel
kernel
of the linux operating system it turned
out to be in little pieces of code that
have to do with the device drivers
the linux operating system kernel um it
was
deep in the low-level sort of nervous
system of the computer
it wasn't something wasn't like oh
that's code i wrote you know
it must be you know i made a mistake it
was deep
in the low-level code of the operating
system
so like how could this be happening well
i i have to say i asked them
friends of mine who who work on sort of
low-level operating system things and
they said
oh yeah the the device drivers and linux
they're terrible
you know it's like but that's the most
common operating system used in the
world
how can you say they tell well it's just
an open source operating system it's not
very good
but whatever but that that's a that's am
that's just one of the funny things that
happens in the world but in any case the
point was this was a
very well trafficked piece of code and
there was something going wrong with it
in the end it turned out oh i i went
through a whole chain of debugging of
whether it was to do with file system
access whether it was to do with all
kinds of other things
turned out to be a stupid problem that
some other part of our infrastructure
was sending all kinds of interrupts into
the operating system asking it to do
other things
and the operating system was like oh let
me look at that interrupt oh let me look
at that interrupt
and it was wasting time doing that and
wasn't sort of concentrating on the task
that had actually been given
but that was a i mean that took a couple
of days to maybe a day or two to debug
once
once one had gone in and really tried to
do sort of data science saying
let's look at billions of queries and
see what's happening and so on
i mean i i could tell you many many many
other debugging stories i would say
most of the debugging stories that
revolve around me are it gets to me when
when it's really been a nasty bug and
it's taken months and people have been
very confused and eventually i say
as a very uh i'd say at some level
ultimately hands-on ceo
it's like let me let me see if i can
actually understand what's going on
um i could tell you one other story like
that
of um more recent couple months ago
again something to do with our network
connectivity
um and uh there was
we could tell that certain network
accesses
were slow and it was affecting a bunch
of our cloud infrastructure
and it's like what's going on and people
are saying well some of our network
accesses are really slow
and uh some of them aren't even
connecting at all but some of them
really slow
and it's like we don't know what's
happening this is some kind of
connection that's flapping and
it's you know sometimes it's working
sometimes it's not working what's going
on
etc etc etc that one took a few hours to
debug but that one
what i eventually noticed is let's just
take all of these queries
that and see you know we've got a query
it's going to this particular ip address
uh this particular place on the internet
we got another query it's going to this
particular place on the internet
which of these queries are slow and
which are fast it's just got a bucket
of thousands millions of these queries
and let's just see if we can tell
what's the difference is that are there
is it consistent the ones going to a
particular
uh ip address are slow and one's going
to other ip addresses so fast
so it turned out we discovered that it
was a problem
with the way that a very upstream
internet service provider was passing
traffic
to another large internet service
provider only
but just one particular provider and it
all the other
things went through just fine but with
that one particular provider
it was blocking it for some reason or it
was it was incorrectly connected
and so it looked like well most queries
are going just fine but some are not
working
turned out it was very consistent set
that weren't working but it wasn't quite
as consistent as you might have thought
because some of these places that the
queries were going to had multiple
different exposure points on the on the
internet
and so it they could go through
different paths and so on but any case
that was a that was an example but
but usually you know i would say that
that um
uh these kinds of bugs and computer
systems these are complicated
and you know my observation is that
solving them it's a big part of the
story is use kind of data science type
methods use
use computation to solve these bugs take
in large amounts of data actually
analyze it make graphs
plot out things don't just try and do
the thing
that people so often do is say let's
look at the log file
let's read through 10 000 log messages
and see if we notice something going on
us humans are not that good at that you
know have a computer do it if necessary
and i've done this
too use natural language processing or
use various kinds of machine learning on
log files
to go and figure out where the anomalous
pieces of these log files
can you figure out what's happening and
there's a decent chance you'll succeed
at doing that
but those are some kinds of things i
mean i would say there's one bug
right now that uh we're probably going
to fix
because we have some very old hardware
that we're using for some of our
services um we're probably going to just
fix it by buying new hardware
um but there's a bug where certain kinds
of
process restarts are running out of
memory or at least they report that
they're running out of memory but when
we look at how much memory they have
they seem to have enough memory and
that's one where i've been telling the
team
uh you know this is again just go look
inside the operating system you can go
read the code of the operating system
and say but but you know but we don't
really want to do that
but look we can see there are there are
10 places where this particular message
that we are getting
can be generated you might think oh if
you can read the code of the operating
system
just instrument them to see what's
happening it's vastly more complicated
than that unfortunately
and it's not it's not so clear what's
going on but this is a case where
where it's like we'd we'd kind of like
to debug this but
in the end it's probably not worth it
because it's we need to buy new hardware
anyway
and the new hardware will almost
certainly make this problem go away
another another type of problem oh i
could talk about many of these so so
here's an example of a type of issue
it's pretty complicated
is you have let's say you have a
thousand computers
and you have zillions of people who are
trying to make requests of those
computers
request comes in you have to say okay
computer number 217 is free right now
let's send the request to that computer
okay
another request comes in another
computer is free let's send the request
to that computer
okay let's say most of the computers are
working on something
and you want to know can which computer
should you queue up a request
to to which computer should you if
you're sending
successive requests to different
computers which ones should you send
them to
that's a a problem of so-called load
balancing you don't want
kind of uh well it's also relevant if
some of these computers are connected to
the same memory subsystems
connected to the same networks and so on
you don't want to sort of
make this particular set of computers
really really busy
while these other ones over here have
nothing to do you want to
sort of spread the load over these
different computers so there's a
complicated kind of issue of load
balancing
of how do you how do you send successful
requests to different computers
and so there are different strategies
like least recently used might be a
strategy
which is to say okay the request that
comes in send it to the computer
that was least recently sent a request
another thing you might do is to say uh
well which computers have finished
which computers are are almost finished
with the requests that they're running
right now
so we can queue up a new request to that
computer well the problem with that is
depends on what kind of requests they're
dealing with because maybe those
requests
let's say real case for us our world
from alpha queries
well from alpha queries the query might
be a really easy one to answer but it
might be really complicated to answer
so it's very hard to know how long that
request is actually going to take
so if you get queued up behind some
requests that's going to take five
seconds
you're in bad shape because your request
is going to be is going to be waiting
for five seconds to be done
so it's kind of a complicated thing to
figure out the strategy
of how you should do this kind of load
balancing particularly when you have
these
very variable and very unpredictable
amounts of time that will be spent on
different
uh different requests and so that's a
place where
oh we've had all kinds of issues in in
figuring out the optimal way to do load
balancing i'm afraid the main result
of theoretical load balancing
discussions is
uh any fanciness isn't going to help you
anything you do where you're trying to
be very fancy about predicting this and
that and the other
in the end sort of computational
irreducibility bites you
and in the end just the the kind of most
simple-minded
uh approaches tend to be the most robust
and that's the thing we've actually
discovered in practice um uh more often
than we might like
let's see um
well okay let me let me do a couple more
here
um
there's a question here from red lantern
how quickly is technology advancing
at the moment is science reliable in the
grand scheme of things okay this
question about
how quickly technology is advancing it's
often fun for me to talk to
friends of mine in technology industry
and so on
and some people are like there's a
singularity technology is advancing
faster and faster and faster
and you know it's all exponential and so
on
and then there are other people who are
saying i haven't heard a new idea in
years
so how can both these things be true
well i think one point is that what
tends to happen in the advance of
technology as in science
is that new some new methodology
typically is invented some new
kind of direction is is defined and then
a lot of stuff happens in that direction
for a certain period of time
you know machine learning starts to be
real okay for a decade
really interesting things get figured
out there you know computer graphics
starts to be good
for a decade really interesting things
get figured out there's lots of visible
progress
you know the idea of social networks
gets developed there's lots of progress
there for a certain period of time
the idea of laser printers gets gets
invented there's lots of progress for a
certain period of time
but if you ask if you say given the
areas that you already know about
how much progress is there the answer is
by the time you know about it
and particularly if everybody knows
about it there probably isn't that much
progress that's going to happen
because it's kind of something where the
you know it's had its five or ten years
of sort of rapid progress from this sort
of methodological advance
and so you um uh you really
uh you you end up it ends up seeming
like
if you say let me take this set of
things that i already know kind of what
they are
and then say is there lots of progress
in those well the answer might be not
really
the progress happens because new things
are invented
that are things that were quite
different from the things you already
defined
so a very typical thing is there'll be
some domain the remain will develop to a
certain point
people will say we really want to you
know recognize
progress in this domain let's set up a
prize for this particular domain
you know the best physics the best uh
you know social network the best
whatever okay
pretty much i think it's a fair
statement that as soon as there's a
prize for something
the most fertile period is probably over
because as soon as you can bucket it to
the point where you say
there's this definite thing and there's
stuff happening and yeah there's
incremental progress happening
but you know the places where it's
really going to look dramatic and
really exciting are really different
really unexpected
real progress happening are the places
where there wasn't a prize set up yet
because nobody even thought that was a
thing yet so
so i think that what what one sees is
there's sort of a
lots of when you define progress in a
particular way
then inevitably it tends to slow down if
you're sort of open to progress
can be sort of anything and it may even
be a different definition of what we
mean by progress
then yes there's sort of an infinite
frontier of possible things to discover
and invent
and it looks fast and you know i would
say that
in my you know i've been sort of paying
attention to technology for
oh gosh probably 50 years now and um in
in um uh and there are things where
it's like wow this is happening very
quickly and it's like oh my gosh i can't
believe we're still at this stage you
know
40 years ago we were at a stage just
only a tiny bit
before that so i think the um you know
there are particular areas where there
will be
you know no doubt rapid advances in
technology and others where they won't
be i mean like
for instance i don't know uh you know
smartphones
you know there was a period of rapid
advance and then it's like do i really
need a new phone do i really need a
bigger camera
you know laptop computers you know do i
really need that
that extra little twiddle i don't know
it's it's not doesn't feel like it's
dramatic progress
but at the beginning it was certainly
dramatic progress
so i think this is something one can
expect to see and if one if one's
picking a particular domain
the thing may get worked out and there
may be only incremental progress
if one is sort of open to all
possibilities then
then things will tend to look like
there's there's more and faster progress
and i think um uh the um
let's see um
i'm going to uh do one more
[Music]
um
okay question from adit
says um i'm 16 reasonably intelligent
this person
says but nowhere even close to genius
hard to know i like the self-belief to
achieve my dream very successful career
in ai
i feel i'm not smart enough i feel that
all people there in the community are
geniuses
and i feel like i cannot make it so how
is it possible to overcome this kind of
self-doubt that's an interesting
question i think that um
you know there are lots of different
ways
to succeed make progress
discover things invent things whatever
else
and i think one of the things
you know different people have different
kinds of skills and different ways of
doing things some people
the best thing for them is sit by
themselves and try and figure stuff out
okay they'll come up with something
great um
maybe for other people it's like
be part of some team be maybe even be
the leader of the team
it's like you're not very good at the
actual mechanics of making the thing
work but you're pretty good at figuring
out what should be done
and you know and then if you can work
with other people to actually
actualize what you're talking about then
everything works well
i think that sort of part of the the
first step
in you know doing something where you
achieve some something you're excited
about and by the way
the kinds of things that different
people are excited about maybe
completely different
and it may be that somebody's i really
want that achievement is somebody else's
i couldn't care less about that
and vice versa um so you know
if the if the achievement you want is to
discover something interesting about
let's say ai
what do you mean by interesting do you
mean lots of people are going to use it
do you mean it's going to be something
that is going to be intellectual
progress that academic papers get
written about
do you mean it's going to be some
different kind of thing where
where you know that there are there are
different definitions of success
and in terms of what it takes to to to
achieve those different definitions of
success there are also
typically many paths to those things and
i think
that the the number one issue is sort of
defining what the objective is
in other words if you say i have this
great idea and
you know i have this great thing that i
want to achieve then
it's like okay how do you take the steps
to achieve that but
even just this act of saying i've got
this great thing i want to achieve
and defining that thing that's a very
important step
and if you can do that you're already
kind of way ahead
because just knowing well if i do this i
do this i do this
then i'm going to make a great discovery
or whatever it's just not really the way
that you know
it's not sort of a procedure there's not
a kind of set
sequence of steps that people take to
get to the point where
they can do something sort of unexpected
and um
uh and and something that that uh that
they consider to be an exciting
achievement so i think i'm i would tend
to feel
that um uh well also there's this
question
of um uh uh you you mentioned that um
sort of everybody in the community
around you seems to be
sort of a genius and and how do you fit
into this
uh i think that is um
uh you know i don't know i'm not sure
that the comparison of people
in that way is particularly productive
and one of the things i've noticed
i suppose um some parts of the world
maybe silicon valley is a particularly
bad example of this
at different times in its history is you
know people will always
make themselves out to be a lot more
geniusy
than perhaps they really are it's like
it's like let's use a complicated word
when a simple word would work just fine
but it makes
it sound more geniusy if we use a
complicated word and then the person
you're talking to doesn't know what
you're talking
about um and and sometimes that
that's usually uh in my observation
usually but not always a bad sign i mean
there are people
uh where you talk to them and they only
talking very complicated words
and it's like blah blah blah blah and
it's like how can this be something real
and interesting
and you pick it apart and you realize
this person is pretty bad at explaining
things
but what they're saying is really very
interesting and that can happen
um but it's it's i think uh you know
it's not just because there are fancy
words me used means
doesn't mean that the thing being talked
about is fancier so to speak
and just because there are simple words
being used doesn't mean that the thing
is being talked about is necessarily
sort of mundane and simple and i think
somehow my observation is that that
well since i like to work in a lot of
different kinds of fields
i am constantly in this situation of
feeling like
uh there are lots of people in this
field who are a lot smarter about this
field than i am
uh you know how can i possibly make
progress in this field
except somehow i managed to do it a
whole bunch of times how can that be
well uh what are some some examples of
of things that happen one thing is the
experts
in some particular area they tend to
know
they know exactly what to do and they're
in this path and they're they're running
around
and they know what to do because they're
experts and
but they're not looking at some bigger
question
some something that maybe comes from
outside their field
that suddenly it doesn't work to just
make that little sort of micropath
there's suddenly this other thing that
you can make progress with
and you don't feel as smart as the
people who are experts in that field
because they're telling you all these
complicated things about this field and
what about this and you know you're
thinking about this well
surely you can't be able to do that
because of this footnote that says this
and that and the other thing
and it's it's like you could come to the
conclusion that no no it's hopeless i
can't possibly do anything in that area
but actually somehow it often seems to
work out just great
and i think you know it is worth knowing
a certain amount about these areas but
if you drill too deep
and you get too involved in oh the
minutiae
and what about this what about that you
can easily lose sight of whatever big
picture
you potentially can can can get to but i
think that um
a thing that that's worth realizing is
particularly if you
try to work in in a sequence of
different fields you try and make
contributions in different areas
uh i i can say at least from my own
experience one is continually finding
oneself
pretty humbled by by the kinds of things
that people in those fields already know
like for example i mentioned earlier
here that i've been thinking a little
bit about economics recently
and i don't really know anything about
economics and i'm
you know i've i've sort of heard about
it for years and i've kind of
known lots of people who've been
distinguished in that field and i've
you know i've i've i've kind of looked
at the pictures and the textbooks and
i've
kind of seen people use our technology
to do things in economics but i don't
really know economics in the sense that
you know
if i was doing some you know
standardized exam about it i doubt i
would uh
i doubt i think there'd be plenty of
questions where i wouldn't know the
answer
um and and yet how can i be thinking
about doing something that
might have significance in that field
well i kind of
uh i think the uh maybe it's just pure
you know confidence or arrogance
that one can do this except that it has
worked for me many times
so i don't think it's uh it's completely
a misplaced idea
but i think that the point is that you
know yes
there will constantly be people who are
experts
things to know that you don't know the
question is can you
define what your objective is well
enough and at least
learn things enough along the path that
you need to go on
that you can be successful in achieving
that path
and i think um um
i mean in terms of the the the personal
question of
of how do you conclude that you can do
it
versus not i think that ends up being a
thing that comes mostly from from inside
one
and i've been fortunate in my life that
i've i worked on a bunch of different
things i started out
doing sort of things when i was pretty
young
that were reasonably successful and uh
you know
i started writing physics papers and
things like that when i was a
teenager and um uh you know they they
were
they worked out just fine and having had
certain successes
you build confidence to say things like
what i'm saying now which is
i can just sort of walk into this area
of economics that say well i know
you know little about and make a useful
contribution so to speak
now you know you kind of build up after
probably decades
to that level of either confidence or
arrogance depending on how you look at
it
um and i'm not sure that that's that's
the place you start
and i think that a good place to start
is
you know you pick something that's a
pretty modest objective
and perhaps you pick something which is
out of the mainstream
of oh everybody's working on ai and
they're trying to solve this problem and
that problem
we'll pick a problem that seems like
it's it's a little problem off on the
corner here
that isn't something where there's
thousands of people working on that and
there's a
you know don't pick the problem of for
example a robot
grasping at something which is a very
difficult kind of ai like problem
because
zillions of people are working on that
you know if you pick a
problem that's a little tiny sub problem
of that that's still
kind of interesting like you know how do
you pick a particular kind of fruit or
something
you know how do you make a robotic
manipulation that picks a particular
kind of fruit or
a bad example but but um something like
that and
and you know you kind of get yourself
sort of completely
around that particular thing which
perhaps nobody else cares about right
now
and then go solve it and that kind of
builds you
a certain amount of confidence and yes i
can actually solve these things and then
you go for the next thing and the next
thing and so on
the issue of solving things which is
sort of out of the main
uh out of the the sort of main main path
main track
is sometimes you'll solve those things
and you'll be very satisfied yes i
solved it i come up with this really
great solution
oops nobody cares about this well then
you have to convince people they should
care
or you just take it as something where
it's like well i figured this out
i learned something from doing this i
got satisfaction out of doing it
uh it's like i put it in this little you
know wrap it up
tight tie a bow uh put it you know tied
in a bow and uh
and put it aside so to speak and then go
on to the next
you know perhaps bigger thing anyway
that that's a um
uh uh um that would be
my my comment i think the the concept of
um uh you know
it's a very personality dependent thing
if you say i'm going to set myself up
for this thing i'm going to try and do
it
um and uh you know maybe it's too hard
and uh if you say well maybe i'm gonna
fail you keep looking down
you keep saying maybe i'm gonna fall the
chance of falling is much higher
i think many people like myself for
example who work
on big complicated projects you know
it's like this thing isn't going to fail
i don't even have to think about it
failing
it's it's going to succeed and you know
by golly
maybe the original thing that i was
originally hoping might happen
doesn't actually happen but you know but
it ends up being the case that one
navigates to something
which is a good uh a good result and i
think that the um
uh the thing that um uh so so that this
kind of
but what if i fail type thing tends to
be rather
uh it's like just just pick something
where you're pretty confident
you know even if it's small you you can
get yourself to the point where you're
pretty confident
you can do it and then just try doing it
and uh
you know and and you also have to think
about okay if you fail you try and do
some projects and the project doesn't
work out
maybe you didn't even tell anybody about
the project okay
it's a pity it didn't work out but it's
not terribly embarrassing
it's not um there's not uh you know
maybe you waste a little bit of time
maybe you learn something doing it
it doesn't have a high cost um so i
think it's it's one of these things
where
where um you know if you can define what
you want to do and it's kind of like
like just try doing something now now
you know i would say
that if you say okay i'm gonna build a
general ai
i'm going to solve the problem of
artificial intelligence and things
that's probably not a great problem to
to work on i mean if you
if you think i mean i would pick a
something a more specific sub problem
that
is one that hasn't necessarily been
worked on a lot and i would kind of
you know get all over that problem and
you know just the sort of thing i'm i'm
going to sit
and invent you know the great new theory
of everything
it's kind of not the way it works it's
kind of when you when you
imagine i mean you know you have to
when you when you work on big projects
you end up
making many sub goals for those projects
and
if you're not experienced at doing
really big projects
it's not a great idea to just say i'm
going to do this huge project
from the beginning better idea to pick a
smaller project where you can readily
sort of see your way
to where you want to get to and and um
it's uh i mean you know in in in my
efforts for example in finding
fundamental theory of physics okay that
wasn't a thing where i sat down when i
was
you know i was thinking about things
like that when i was you know 15 16
years old but
i didn't you know i didn't wasn't
sitting down with a blank sheet of paper
would have been paper in those days
saying i'm gonna you know i'm gonna
write down the fundamental theory of
physics
i didn't expect that was going to work
instead it's sort of a
a you know a 40-year journey that
involves doing many specific concrete
things
and then realizing oh there's this
particular piece of progress that can be
made and it has these consequences
let's go for that oh there's this
particular thing that can be done let's
go for that
and i think sort of being concrete in
these goals
is important defining kind of uh you
know defining the goals
as i say i think is is the most
important thing figuring out the path by
which you get to the goals
is typically easier than defining the
goals but don't imagine that the goals
should be
you know solve the general ai problem
starting from a blank sheet of paper
that's not
that's not the right kind of goal pick a
goal that is
much more honest and if if you're going
to make a mistake in picking the goals
make the mistake on being too modest in
the goals you know to have something
that's really you know you like i know i
can do this it's only going to take me a
week
and you know i really know rather than i
don't know how i'm going to do this i'm
just
imagining it so to speak um i think
that's that would be my suggestion
all right well lots of interesting
questions um
left over for another time um and
uh uh thank you for the diversity of
topics and questions you've been asking
um i have lots of fun talking about
these kinds of things
and uh i hope uh hope
you find this interesting and um thanks
for
thanks for joining us and see you
another time bye for now
you